[Musique]
bonjour Samin nourri bonjour bienvenue
sur ce plateau dans les prochaines
minutes que nous allons passer ensemble
on va raconter ce qui s'avère être au
final une très belle histoire la vôtre
vous avez 26 ans et vous publiez ce
livre coécrit avec Olivia Caram la
machine à coudre de l'Afghanistan guerre
au défilé de haute couture vous êtes
parti de votre Afghanistan natal à l'âge
de 5 ans après les années d'errance en
Iran puis en Turquie vous finissez par
atterrir en France où vous êtes en train
de vous faire un nom grâce à la couture
on va s'améliorer inhabituellement
commencer par la fin on va commencer par
votre actualité comme on dit
généralement la Fashion Week débute la
semaine prochaine vous y organisez votre
propre défilé déjà comment est-ce que
les choses s'annoncent les choses je
suis je travaille le jour et la nuit et
on va dire
le temps il me reste pas beaucoup de
temps et je suis pressé de présenter une
nouvelle collection
octobre au solume Paris c'est un endroit
secret magique et qu'elle sera le temps
de cette collection
le temps le temps c'est à dire qu'est-ce
que vous voulez présenter en fait cette
fois-ci je vais présenter je vais parler
plus de la de l'actualité qui se passe
je vais parler plus de la liberté de
femmes c'est des tenues on va dire plus
Robert sexy
[Musique]
et c'était assassiné et à cause de ça ma
famille a décidé quitter l'Afghanistan
pour nous sécuriser vous retrouver en
Iran on a vu passer tout à l'heure une
photo de vous avec un objet fétiche
c'est la machine à coudre c'est un objet
qui vous suivra toute votre vie toute la
vie en fait j'ai l'impression que je
suis née avec ça et jusqu'à aujourd'hui
bon il est toujours avec moi je quand je
me lève je le vois quand je dors je le
vois aussi alors cette machine à coudre
c'était l'outil de travail de votre père
qui était tailleur et
vous partez donc ça sera là les reins
puis la Turquie et la France comment
est-ce que vous atterrissez en France
en fait on n'avait pas décidé de on
avait pas choisi un pays mais c'est vrai
que le passeur il pouvait pas passer
toute la famille ensemble il fallait que
je ne sais pas et il avait proposé à ma
famille que voilà je peux ramener votre
fiche premier après vous finalement moi
je pensais qu'il y a une semaine après
deux semaines je vais rejoindre mes
parents et quand on arrivait en France à
Tours et le passeur Baila il a pris
l'argent il m'a il m'a laissé tomber et
finalement voilà j'ai atterri un mois et
demi après deux mois j'ai su que je suis
en France au début je savais même pas je
suis dans quel pays ou dans parce que
quand vous atterrissez ici vous ne
parlez pas un seul mot de français ni
anglais
donc uniquement votre votre langue
natale
le perse d'Harry alors comment se passe
justement ces premiers moments en France
le première fois que j'ai parlé j'ai pas
parlé déjà c'était le commissariat en
fait du m'ont demandé mon il voulait me
demander mon âge mais il savait pas
comment communiquer parce que je parlais
né anglais ni français ils avaient ils
avaient dessiné un gâteau sur un tableau
avec des bougies avec des chiffres à
côté il commence à chanter le joyeux
anniversaire pour savoir mon âge mais
après ça bah j'étais placé dans un foyer
au bout de 6 mois j'étais j'étais au
collège pour apprendre la langue petit à
petit j'ai appris donc ça commence comme
ça heureusement dirons-nous il y a un
Dieu pour les pour les malheureux
puisque vous allez être remarqué par des
professeurs des enseignants qui verront
que vous avez un talent pour coudre un
jour je rentre de l'école et je voyais
que la femme de ménage dans le foyer il
faisait des des petites retouches des
petits trucs
les serviettes etc j'ai demandé de
d'utiliser la machine à coudre et elle
voulait pas amuser c'est trop dangereux
et tout et j'ai insisté et finalement il
m'a laissé faire il a vu que je sais
faire et après elle m'a prêté sa machine
à coudre et pendant la nuit dans ma
chambre je faisais des petits trucs pour
moi des t-shirts des pantalons et tout
et avec ça je suis allé au collège et de
ma prof principal qui est remarqué ça et
elle m'a demandé où comment qui il fait
tout ça les vêtements et j'ai expliqué
que c'est moi elle m'a dit bah il faut
faire ça elle m'a fait toutes les
démarches pour rentrer au lycée bac pro
et après ça va j'ai fait stage par un
stage justement là dessus il y a tout un
apprentissage qui se mettent en place ça
me nourrit vous êtes entré chez Galliano
si j'ai bien compris vous avez découvert
Dior vous admirez Alexander McQueen mais
j'ai cru comprendre aussi que vous aviez
un faible pour Jean-Paul Gaultier
qu'est-ce que représente Jean-Paul
Gaultier pour vous car si vous avez
appris bah c'est c'est pour moi c'est
c'est un grand personne parce que c'est
quand même grâce
que j'ai plusieurs avoir apprendre le
savoir-faire haute couture les
différentes matières les
la haute couture déjà parce que moi
j'avais travaillé que dans la confection
de faire des 200 300 pièces par semaine
avec mon père mais c'est vrai que
travailler avec lui c'est de
pour moi c'est
vous avez découvert le fait main le le
le produit travailler confectionner
point par point à la main les finitions
les les matières les beaucoup de choses
et pour moi c'est le meilleur créateur
en tout cas français d'aujourd'hui
finalement vous lancez sa minorit votre
propre griffe votre propre marque le
premier motif c'est le barbelé quelle
est la signification du barbelé dans
votre travail en fait non quand j'ai
créé ma marque j'ai réfléchi qu'est-ce
que je peux faire etc je m'inspire
d'abord de tenue traditionnelle de un
pays et que de tout ce que j'ai vécu et
après le signature j'ai repris les
barbelés parce que toutes les frontières
que j'ai passé j'ai été enfermé et je
cherchais la liberté et j'ai passé les
barbelés pour passer dans un pays libre
et tous et tous ces barbelés chaque
frontière est remarqué j'ai j'ai je me
suis dit je prends ça comme signature et
aujourd'hui sur très souvent dans mes
dans mes créations on voit les motifs
par voler soit sur l'école soit sur les
manches sauf le
ces voyages ont marqué votre travail
s'aménorrhée et votre passage en Iran
par exemple
expliquez-nous ce que vous faites de
tchador d'une burqa
je trouve d'un voile mais moi c'est à
partir d'un voile un chat d'or je fais
une je fais des créations je fais des
robes je fais tout à partir d'un chat
d'heure et et pour moi je trouve que une
femme il a besoin sa liberté on n'a pas
le droit de on n'est pas là pour
l'obliger de porter ce que soit un
shader soit un burqa mais c'est juste
que c'est c'est des tenues
traditionnelles et à partir de là quand
je quand je mette sur un mannequin
shaderwan un burqa et à partir de là je
le coupe de toutes les façons et je le
fais une robe sexy Voilà il se trouve
que heureusement malheureusement nous
sommes rattrapés par l'actualité on a
raconté l'histoire de ces femmes
iraniennes qui sont en train de
manifester en ce moment et
pour contrôler la mort de la jeune Marsa
dans des conditions et épouvantables
alors quand vous voyez ces femmes en
Iran s'améli qui manifeste en brûlant
leur voile parfois qu'est-ce que cela
vous inspire
j'espère qu'un jour il trouvera leur
liberté parce que c'est vrai que c'est
pas c'est pas facile c'est pas facile
parce que
si il se battent pour leur liberté c'est
bien parce que
c'est une obligation même moi j'ai ma
sœur qui allait à quelques il y a de
deux ans et demi en Iran faire avec ma
mère pour en tant que touriste elle sait
faire battait aussi elle finit
à la poste et il fallait que ma mère
elle a acheté un
chat dort pour que elle se fait libérer
mais bon heureusement qu'elle avait les
papiers français
elles étaient pas très embêtés c'est
vrai que c'est super dangereux là-bas je
trouve que c'est catastrophique quoi de
moi je connais un peu comment ça marche
dans le sens que j'ai vécu j'ai été
petit on même pas sortir dans la rue
parce qu'on n'avait pas de papier je
sais très bien qu'elle est police
comment est-ce qu'on porte avec les avec
les gens et surtout avec les femmes qui
qui se battent pour leur liberté là on
l'espèce en Iran c'est la police des
mœurs qui est qui est mise en cause ces
dernières années autre sujet s'améliori
vu l'expérience que vous avez vécu je me
vois obligé un peu de vous poser la
question on a assisté à une quantité de
ce qu'on appelle de drame de de
l'immigration la Méditerranée est
devenue un gigantesque cimetière
qu'est-ce que vous dites à toutes ces
personnes candidates à l'exil qui sont
jetés sur les routes qui sont parfois
exploitées par des passeurs qu'est-ce
que vous vous leur dites
franchement sur ça je sais pas quoi dire
parce que c'est un sujet politique moi
je fais pas la politique mais je trouve
ça un opinion chacun il peut donner son
avis chacun il pense mais pour moi
voilà je mais en tout cas vous savez
qu'on ne part pas comme ça de son plein
gré c'est pas parce qu'on le veut
bien sûr certainement moi
personnellement quand je suis parti de
mon pays je suis pas parti pour les
vacances pour au danger avec ma vie
personnelle ou ma ma famille il a pas
décidé ça pour mettre en danger la vie
des enfants ou ma mère mais c'est vrai
que on a personnellement on avait des
problèmes pour se battre pour la liberté
après
je trouve que voilà c'est
un sujet politique
évidemment ce n'est pas le le propos
rapidement votre histoire s'améliorer à
censé être adapté à l'écran et vous
voudriez qu'il y ait un acteur
particulier qui vous qui vous incarne
c'est qui cet acteur en tout cas moi
j'aimerais beaucoup que Pierre Niney qui
joue mon rôle après pourquoi lui
qui vous ressemble il me ressemble en
tout cas il me ressemble et c'est un
acteur qui qui j'aime beaucoup la façon
comment elle joue etc je pour moi c'est
lui bon après
merci beaucoup
jusqu'à nous merci pour cette très belle
histoire inspirante vous publiez ce
livre avec Olivia Caram la machine à
coudre de l'Afghanistan en guerre au
défilé de haute couture qu'est-ce qu'il
vous faut vous souhaitez la semaine
prochaine pour un Fashion Week je
souhaite que
toutes les jeunes qui voient ça qui
c'est un message que même si on n'a pas
de moyens etc qu'on peut réussir il faut
pas lâcher l'affaire et moi je me
souhaite que je puisse réussir le 2
octobre présenter une belle collection
que les gens ils vont aimer et voilà ne
pas lâcher l'affaire merci Samin
nourrice c'était l'invité de Paris
direct l'information internationale
continue sur une chaîne